do you suddenly have a lot of time on
your hands then come on down and can't
lose the big game oh please come get me
little trust can't lose the game Oh have
you heard the news that's right sports
fans it's actually cool to lose with
activities such as where the is the flag
make me fly Kyler do you guys think
we'll ever be too old to play games all
day
my made a friendship bracelet we've got
the lead baby
this talent you're just using it friend
look I'm gonna be covered a gap dumped
glitter but at least I'll fluff and try
so I turned the corner and what do I see
it's a team that saw it on defense and
offense good old taste the pain bros hey
lights off the lights a little longer
horsemen are your time Sally's thing is
the championship camp across the lake
wow it's a bit dark camp friends aren't
real friends
[Music]
Taysom subscribe to this channel for me
yes sir Taysom animate me my own Super
Bowl trophy of course sir
Taysom make me feel less broken inside
sir that's the one thing I can't do